[Applaudissements]
si je vous dis légumes nationale de
hockey ne pensait sûrement pas
spontanément à contrôle de l'information
et pourtant les exemples sont nombreux
dans ce sport qui frise la religion pour
bien des canadiens
[Musique]
notre collègue alexandre de gaston est
très bien placé pour observer le
phénomène de près depuis plusieurs
années y suit le canadien de montréal
aux quatre coins de la ligue
[Musique]
donc alexandre du contrôle de
l'information sa existence pas aussi
comment les équipes la lnh font pour
contrôler l'information
essentiellement ce qu'on essaie de faire
c'est de contrôler le message donc de
contrôler ce que les journalistes vont
dire de notre équipe
alors évidemment ce sont eux qui donnent
l'accès aux médias aux joueurs de
l'équipe joue des possibilités de grands
disponibles les joueurs qu'on veut bien
qu'ils parlent cette journée là où
al'inverse éviter certaines
confrontations entre journalistes et
joueurs ça marche chaque ça tout le
monde comment ça fonctionne quand on
rentre dans un vestiaire la ligue
nationale le match terminé qu'est pas
l'obligation d'ouvrir ses portes 5
lunettes avec le match dernier les
journalistes sont liquides du loup dans
la porte du vestiaire on nous le
vestiaire il ya des joueurs qui ont
généralement ceux qui sont pas là à ce
moment là il ya de bonnes chances qu'on
les voit porte bien en forme de contre
information là bien évidemment on va
remettre en question puisque et les
blessures les commotions cérébrales qui
le sujet très très frileux dans la ligue
nationale maintenant parce qu'elle
proverbiale haut du corps body cawi
on a vu un esprit qui anime une
consolante est violemment
c'est lorsqu'il tombe sur un modèle vaut
mieux c'est si une blessure et régna ce
parce qu'il s'est cogné la tête sur la
glace c'est le score qui a encaissé on
veut pas divulguer cette information là
parce qu'on a peur de ce que les autres
joueurs pour enfin c'est pas vrai
qu'aujourd'hui dans la ligue nationale
des joueurs d'une autre équipe parce que
tout le petit doigt fracturé monféry tu
peux te donner un coup sûr le petit
doigt mais ce qu'on oublie parfois le
fait que les équipes se sont dit les
entreprises privées exact théoriquement
n'ont pas de comptes à rendre
à la population théoriquement ces
canadiens de montréal on pourrait
disserter longuement c'est simplement
c'est la sainte flanelle ça fait partie
de la culture au québec à montréal il ya
un lien très fort avec les partisans de
l'alors les canadiens conscient qu'il
doit se doit quand même donner de
l'information puis du divertissement à
sa base de partisans et ça ça passe par
les médias toutes les équipes de la
ligue nationale maintenant leur propre
entreprise médiatique si je peux dire
leurs propres journalistes à montréal
s'est abstenu brouns tv vient de partout
rien peuvent contourner le filtre des
journalistes
exactement erreur propres c'est souvent
plus du film good story le gamin pendant
la controverse
une façon de constitution tolère
dacquois de transmission traditionnelle
entre les journalistes et les bases d'un
terminal ex ans que je comprends sexta
géométrie variable le contrôle
d'information ça dépend des équipes des
marchés ça forcément à toronto c'est
très très difficile
généralement ils sortent les joueurs il
les place sur un podium il a tout le
monde est rassemblé autour donc pas dire
qu'on vieillit très peu de conversation
intime et al'inverse si vous débarquez
en arizona où analyse par exemple a peut
être plus facile de faire son travail à
ce moment là la lnh au milieu de
supporters mieux conservées plus
conservateur que la nba c'est là c'est
l'exemple parfait lundi garder cas
hollande
le garde des rappeuses de tonton quant
aux déchets ou ce qu'on est en
conférence de presse pour longtemps
après pour expliquer absolument tout ce
qui s'était passé à partir du moment où
je quittais des reins qui a vu les
docteurs sont adonnés à des années
lumière de ce qui se fait dans la ligue
nationale match changeait alors de voir
les ventes s'ouvrir puis la transparence
dominé pas que ça arriverait jamais je
posterai merci beaucoup à la bonne
saison
[Musique]
et vous trouvez-vous que les équipes de
la lnh sont assez transparente souvent
des choses qui sont cachés nous
bombarder fameuse blessure ou encore vos
bottes score des pistes en tribu fois la
question et j'y suis sereine sa gamme
qui je veux quand même assez bien ce
vade des story pour les réseaux sociaux
ça c'est bien
[Musique]
des choses cachées par des parents
veulent tout dire aux partisans fait les
partisans d'avoir engagé envers l'équipe
simplement les sénateurs d'ottawa
il faut quand même assez bien
généralement lorsqu'il ya un blessé ils
disent ça c'est vraiment tout sur puis
c'est quoi la nature de la blessure au
tour de la formation
[Musique]
moi que ces deux
l'ex hockeyeur québécois georges laraque
un jour ils ont quatre équipes de la lnh
agile avec ses bois n'avait pas non plus
la langue dans sa poche
[Musique]
c'est comme cela que je fais je pense à
beaucoup j'ai vu que mon utilisation
mais parler aux médias en général dans
tous les marchés de connu est ce que
cette occasion les problèmes ou est-ce
qu'à certains moments tu as senti qu'on
a voulu contrôler ton message
j'ai toujours eu un franc parler je sais
que 90% de ce que les joies avons dit en
entrevue
c'est parce qu'ils pensent grant hill du
port puis on pose la question petit
idiot je respecte a dit son entraîneur
je travaille fort d'un coup au maximum
c'est pas simple de latence and maintain
je t'aimerai et je te ferai ce que je
pensais être il est que saper ce bug
aussi mis l otan médias ce n'est pas
pareil
montréal c'est pas la même chose à
montréal deux des meilleures choses que
quand tu dis est ce que tu penses ou de
la réponse politique
ça peut créer la controverse et y
joindre un exemple génération avec les
joies de quatrième trio jeudi mais si
j'avais su que la natation je n'aurais
pas signé montréal
cette première page c'est ça c'est
quelque chose comme ça ça vaut fallait
que ça peut exploser
comment ça se fait que dans la ligue
nationale de contrôle dans certains
marchés
c'est plus resserré le hockey c'est une
mentalité différente les doigts qui sont
trop extravagant et ont plus mortelles
des noix joie de feu de barres de toit
de ma glace cas pas maintenant je m'en
souviens qu ajoutait deux jours le feu
bah disant des choses que j'attendais ce
qu'ils disaient 'oh mon dieu ce que
verse aux bâlois qui ont foutrait barre
de l'équipe
on va entendre une conférence de presse
du 15 et de montréal ou d'un joueur sur
sa blessure
c'est le haut du corps c'est le bas du
corps de contrôle l'information sur les
blessures qu'est ce t'en penses deux
choses le bain des équipes des fois
qu'ils disent catherine jacques a décidé
lui qu'il dise exactement
moi ça m'a même désavantage et le haut
du tableau de score parce que il a fallu
que je fasse une entrevue est monde en
parle
quand j'étais libéré par la case et
morales pour esprits aux gens pourquoi
j'ai joué seulement 60 matches en deux
ans page avait des hernies discales
j'ai pensé détachées absolument rien
les cartes et un batailleur ça fait 12
ans que ce travail là j'ai développé
deux handicaps quelque chose que
personne ne pouvait prédire que tu vas
savoir quand aussi c'était quoi la
blessée ont sympathisé
ça m'a pris un an et demi ça a pris
jusqu'à temps que je sois libéré moi je
voulais que les gens sages fallait qu'on
dise aux du corps c'est plus un danger
aujourd'hui dévoilé des blessés donc ça
donne rien de l'a20 du club du corps
donc c'est un exemple qui nous
démontrent leur qui peut changer
il ya de l'espoir finalement porquet ça
soit plus transparent maintenant les
gros marchés
ben oui c'est sûr qu'un nul espoir il ya
un parchemin a demandé de le faire parce
que si tu veux gros c'est là qu'ils se
rendent à pied plus populaires qui peut
pas garder les oies dans une boîte et
peut-être la plus grosse la maison sport
c'est ça
[Musique]